I just want to explain something really
quick when you look at a circle what's a
circle you've got a point okay which is
considered the center point right and
then what you're doing is a circle is
really the set of points okay that are
equidistant okay from a given point you
know that given point called the center
right so when you measure the distance
from that Center okay to any point on
the circle let's just call that point XY
you know it's a fixed distance away and
that distance we call the radius right
so now if you remember the distance
formula remember how the distance
formula is like this it's x2 minus x1
squared plus y2 minus y1 squared and
then we take the square root right well
in this case our two points are going to
be these two points here we're going to
find that distance between them so here
we have X minus H okay so we're
subtracting the x-coordinates squaring Y
minus K so we're just tracking those and
we're squaring and then we're taking the
square root and that distance is equal
to the radius we're going to call that R
now what we're gonna do now is we're
going to square both sides of this
equation so we get R squared equals X
minus H squared plus y minus K squared
like that now
when you learn the distance formula
actually you know flip the solver so
let's go ahead and rewrite this slightly
so X minus H squared plus y minus K the
quantity squared equals the radius
squared so this is our equation for a
circle but the reason I mentioned this
and the reason I show you this is that
imagine if you wanted to find all the
points that were further away okay so
all the set of points that are further
away than this then this distance this
radius right well what you would do then
is you'd say well hmm
instead of making this equals R squared
I want to make it greater than the
radius squared so greater than means is
going to be further away now what
happens if I want to include the points
on the circle say I want this to be like
a solid line of convenience including
all those data points well then it would
be greater than or equal to R squared
right
say I want all the points that are
closer or on the inside of the circle
meaning closer to the center we want
that distance to be less than the radius
right then what we would do is we would
do less
okay or if you want to include the
points that are on the circle as well
less than or equal to so basically if
you know the equation of your circle
this guy right here right you're going
to be able to do the inequalities
greater than further away less than
closer to the center that's the inside
so let's jump into a couple examples
here see if you can do these how would
you write the circle inequality for the
set of points that are shaded here well
let's see we can find the center you can
see the center point is going to be at 3
comma 3 so this is going to be X minus 3
squared plus y minus 3 the quantity
squared right and since we're shading on
the inside of the circle this is going
to be less than not equal to because you
can see this is a dashed or dotted line
for the circle meaning it's not
including the points you know on the
circle and then it looks like our radius
here you can see is a radius of 3 but
remember we want to square that that's
the radius squared so it's going to be
less than 9 okay so you're with me so
far so now if it was equal to you know
we'd include these points on the circle
right ok let's do this one here so
number two it says graph X plus 1
squared plus y squared is greater than
or equal to 4
ok so let's take a look so here the
center is at negative 1 0 okay right CRH
and RK
but remember the one this group with the
axis actually has the opposite effect on
the graph so the plus 1 is actually
shifting it left one and this one you
can see it's really like Y minus 0 or y
plus 0 so it's just going to be here at
negative 1 comma 0 that's our Center and
then the radius is actually to see how
this is R squared
see our square so if we take the square
root that's going to be 2 so I'm going
to go up 2 down 2 right 2 and left 2 ok
just to kind of give us some key points
I'm easy to identify points and see how
this is greater than or equal to so
equal to means it includes the points on
the circle okay as well as the points
that are greater than meaning further
away so we're actually to be shading the
outside of the circle
like that okay so lesson
inside greater than outside equal to
solid line not equal to dashed or dotted
line so a couple of easy examples to to
grasp but again it comes from the
distance formula it also comes from the
equation that we learn about for circles
so that wraps up this video I hope this
helped you to understand this concept
better subscribe to the channel give
this video a thumbs up if you thought it
was helpful and I look forward to seeing
in the future videos I'll talk to you
soon